[Music]
hello and welcome back we are now more
than a week into 2022 and breath of the
wild 2 still hasn't come out what is
this madness in the last video we
explored the new time reversal mechanic
in depth based on the information inside
the patents that were made public in
december of last year if you missed it
there will be a link in the description
and the end card today we'll be doing
the same thing but this time for the
second mechanic passing or phasing
through ceiling object i have again read
through the entire description studied
the diagrams that come with it and
compiled all the stuff interesting
enough to talk about and translated it
into a more easy to understand narrative
as again the actual descriptions are
quite boring and convoluted and just
like last time i'll be providing
custom-made visuals to complement the
explanation since the illustrations
provided inside the patents aren't
always clear so let's go
[Music]
on the surface the mechanic we're
discussing today is pretty
straightforward on a technical level
meaning i don't have to delve too much
into physics and coding again like i did
last time the description mainly refers
to the mechanic as a passing through
movement and was applied for on may 26
2021 its inventors include programmers
haruki sato atsushi asakura and
katsuhisa sato and game slash level
designer yuya sato then either sato is
the most common last name in japan or
the entire sato family is employed by
nintendo
oh well that explains it like i said on
the surface it's a pretty easy concept
to grasp when link is situated
underneath a ceiling object he'll be
able to soar upwards and right through
solid matter until he emerges on the top
side of whatever it is he's passing
through in the teaser we saw this in the
form of link phasing through one of the
islands in the sky and emerging on top
of it this is already a compelling idea
and definitely something we haven't done
before in zelda one interesting thing is
that the text mentions actual gameplay
situations which i found to be quite
intriguing and hints at the type of
stuff we might be seeing in the game it
states that quote therefore for example
the passing through movement allows the
player character to quickly escape from
an underground cave or quickly move on
to the roof from the inside of a
building moreover when there's a cave
beneath a building where the player
character cannot enter because the
entrance door is locked the passing
through movement allows the player
character to enter the building from the
cave i don't know about you but the
scenarios described here really get me
excited i especially like the idea of a
house or building that's locked from the
inside and gaining access to it by
phasing through the ceiling of an open
space or cave located underneath it it's
definitely gonna make you think about
the environment in a completely
different way and has a lot of potential
for hidden secrets we may have even
already seen a hint of this in the 2021
teaser remember that underground cave
where link is seen fighting that weird
ceiling monster thing i mentioned in an
earlier video that the aesthetics of
this area are very similar to the one
seen on top of the floating islands with
the same grey pillars and such and
although we don't have all the
information about the room given the
camera angle so far there's no clear
sign of a doorway leading in and out of
it meaning he could have accessed it
through the floor and the only way out
is through the ceiling so perhaps some
of the islands won't just have stuff on
top of it but on the inside as well the
mechanic itself will consist of four
separate stages the neutral position
when link hasn't activated the ability
the ready position which is when the
ability is activated but not triggered
yet the active position when link is
moving up and through the ceiling object
and the destination position when he
emerges on top of the object and goes
back into neutral position in many ways
it's very similar to the way the sheikah
slate works minus the destination
position
[Music]
according to the description the passing
through movement can only be performed
if a series of conditions are satisfied
these include a movement condition
height condition ceiling condition
destination condition and object
condition the movement condition is
simply the demand that the player is in
possession of whatever allows the
mechanic to be executed this is also
referred to as the movement item which
is basically the same thing as a
progression item although it's called an
item it's safe to say that it likely
refers to the powers that link receives
from his new green glowing arm rather
than a physical item like in the older
games again very similar to the sheikah
slate runes in breath of the wild when
will be able to obtain this power
remains to be seen but without it link
won't be able to perform the move next
is the height condition which kinda
speaks for itself it dictates the
maximum amount of vertical distance link
will be allowed to traverse using the
ability prior to performing the move i.e
during the ready position the game will
detect if there's anything above the
character in video game engines this is
commonly achieved by using a method
known as raycasting as the name suggests
when raycasting the engine will project
one or more invisible lines or rays from
a predetermined origin point and with a
certain length direction and angle when
the ray hits one or more objects in the
game world it'll store various types of
data which can be recalled later things
like the name of the object the distance
between the object and the origin point
and even the angle at which the ray
intersects with the surface and this is
where this illustration comes into play
according to the description six rays
will be casted up from a hexagonal shape
surrounding the base of the character
and the length of these will represent
the height condition if the rays don't
intersect with anything it means that
there's nothing within range located
above link and the jump cannot be
executed and if they do the height
condition will be satisfied it doesn't
mention what the maximum height will be
but it does state that in some specific
scenarios the height condition may be
different or even ignored if there's no
place to be excluded such as a place far
above in the game a height limit need
not be set alternatively the height
limit in the height condition may be set
to an infinite or sufficient height
which means that there is substantially
no height limit so i guess there's
moments in which link will be allowed to
travel up a lot higher or as the text
says without limits this could be
referring to a situation where link uses
the ability to travel between the
surface and the sky for instance
obviously these islands are very very
far above hyrule and in a situation like
this one temporarily disabling the
height limit makes sense in a way you
could compare it to skyward swords
parasail in most scenarios link can only
descend slowly with it or get a small
boost from a gust of wind for as high as
it allows but when traveling to the sky
he is able to cover a massive vertical
distance albeit in a cutscene in this
case maybe there will be pedestals or
something like it located on the surface
from which link can travel to a
designated island but i do suspect that
it's only reserved for very specific
moments under normal circumstances like
in a dungeon setting or during regular
exploration the height limit will likely
always be active we might be able to
upgrade the ability like we did with the
sheikah runes making it possible to
travel higher in later parts of the game
but we'll just have to wait and see the
ceiling condition will judge if the
bottom surface of an object is suitable
for link to pass through this is
determined by the shape as well as
link's position relative to it for
instance if link is too close to the
edge parts of his body would be sticking
out so the condition is not satisfied
same goes when a part of the ceiling
protrudes perpendicular to it and link
overlaps with it in the case of
irregularities in the shape of the
ceiling the condition will be determined
based on the angle if an incline is too
steep link won't be able to pass through
either this is also why six rays are
being casted instead of just one as they
will be needed to calculate the surface
angle in three dimensions then we have
the destination condition which is
pretty much the same thing as the
ceiling condition except for the top
part of the object instead the only
unique aspects to this condition is that
it takes into account whether or not
link will be able to fit in the space
he's traveling to and if there's more
than one passable object located above
link two for instance the destination
may be set to the second object instead
of the first so if object one meets the
ceiling condition but doesn't meet the
destination condition and object 2 meets
both it's possible to pass through
object 1 into object 2 and then emerge
at the destination there which is quite
interesting
[Music]
lastly we have the object condition this
one is more or less an additional
restriction that can override all
previous conditions it simply means that
even if the height position angle and so
on are all satisfactory an object may
still be restricted from passing through
in the illustration this is demonstrated
by a spiked surface but i'd imagine
there will be many more ways to do it
like malice or some other hazard or
perhaps the ability doesn't work for
objects made from a certain material a
bit like the walls inside the sheikah
shrines and the divine beasts which were
unclimbable for no reason other than the
challenge would be negated if they were
climbable and don't tell me they're too
slippery or something ever tried
climbing solid ice with your bare hands
not easy yet link here doesn't even
break a sweat figuratively speaking
obviously this last condition is simply
here so the level designers can prevent
us from completely breaking the game's
progression though i'm sure speedrunners
will find a way as they always do and
finally let's go over some of the
visuals real quick in the video about
the time reversal mechanic i mostly
skipped over visual related stuff
because well we already saw what it
looks like in a teaser for this mechanic
however we only see the tail end of it
we get a very brief glimpse of link
soaring upwards in sort of a diving
position him hitting the ceiling and
crawling inside it and then emerging
from the floor on top of the island the
text elaborates on some of the other
visual elements as well as the camera
positions and optical tricks used before
and during the execution of the move
during the ready position a pillar of
light extending upwards will surround
the character model this is not the same
thing as the raycasting we talked about
earlier by the way as those are
invisible unless you're in debug and
only relevant for the engine to perform
its calculations the only loose
connection it has to it is that the
light pillar will allegedly have the
same vertical length so it's basically a
visual indicator to communicate to the
player where the height limit is this
also brings us to this illustration at
first i had no idea what i was even
looking at here and even the description
of it doesn't really make it clear it's
a follow-up from figure 16 which shows
the character in a neutral position
standing between a floor and a ceiling
the ceiling is indicated by a grid which
is also what we see in figure 17 except
here it's seemingly facing the camera
and has some sort of circle projected on
it so here's the deal the description
states that when the character goes into
the ready position the camera will snap
into an upwards facing position behind
the character a bit like how the camera
snaps to an over the shoulder view when
link draws his bow this way the player
can visually scan the ceiling to find a
suitable spot to pass through the circle
is simply an indicator that shows if the
part of the ceiling you're currently
under is passable or not probably by its
color in the illustration the camera is
pointing straight up at the ceiling and
link himself is not visible but the text
also explains that this might differ
slightly for the final product stating
that quote in the example shown in
figure 17 the player character is not
displayed in another embodiment a part
for example head of the character may be
displayed when a virtual camera is
directed upward the virtual camera may
not necessarily be directed straight
upward and may be oriented such that the
ceiling located above the character is
included in the field of view it doesn't
say if we'll be able to adjust the
camera manually after it's snapped into
position but we'll just have to wait and
see it's likely prone to change during
the development stage depending on what
they find to be the most user-friendly
method to perform the action lastly we
have a little visual trick something
they'll use while link is moving through
an object in the teaser we simply see
the camera panning upwards following
link's movement as he enters and then
emerges from the island while this is
happening link temporarily disappears
from the camera view and we continue to
see the outer walls this matches with
example b shown in figure 18 where the
camera is located outside the object
however as we can see with example a
there will be situations where the
object link is moving through is large
enough that the camera has no space to
back away causing it to move inside the
object with him obviously this kind of
situation is inevitable not only in the
case of a large object but if he's in a
room or cave as the text exemplifies the
camera would have no other choice but to
move through the floor in breath of the
wild when you move the camera inside of
an object in most cases it'll become
partially or completely invisible this
is because of a thing called backface
culling or bfc which is when only one
side of a polygon is rendered so if
you're looking at it from the other
direction where the camera isn't
supposed to be you see nothing this
reduces the amount of polygons the
engine needs to draw and makes rendering
objects quicker and more efficient in
the old days you could move the camera
inside of a house for instance and you
would still see an interior but in
modern games you do not either way it
goes without saying that if the camera
moves inside of an object while link is
moving through it it's gonna look weird
even if they would render the inside
it's just gonna look like a hollow space
the solution presented is that in these
situations the game will place a
background image behind the character
one that will always face towards the
camera and covers its entire field of
view obstructing the real visuals going
on in the background this background
image will likely be a representation of
the material of whatever object link is
moving through like a rock floor for
instance the only example from another
zelda game i can think of from the top
of my head is a link between worlds when
link goes inside of a wall to travel
between dimensions this too is obviously
just an animated background image and
that's about it for the mechanic as
always thank you so much for watching a
shout out to my awesome discord
community and to my amazing patreons and
channel members you guys are the best
that is all for now i hope to see you in
the next video this is dawn signing off
and have a good one
[Music]
you